[Applause]
yall know how this
goes mayy I hear the blues are calling
TOS salads and scrambled
eggs and maybe I seem a bit confused
yeah maybe but I got you
PID but I don't know what to do with
those salad and
[Music]
scram
life's fall again he give it up for the
[Music]
band all
right hey baby I hear the blues are
calling to Sal and
scrambling and maybe I seem a bit
confused yeah maybe but I got you P I
don't
[Music]
know but I don't know what to do with
those tough salad and
[Music]
scrambled
again scrambled eggs all over my face
what is a boy to do I love
you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh you guys welcome to the Kelly
CL tell
everybody give it up for the
b and a big hand from Mr Kelsey Grammar
this is like a dream country true for me
a that was the theme song from his new
series Frasier which is a reboot of
literally possibly I mean that's a top
two show for me of all time Frasier is
like one of my f you have no idea I'm
freaking out right now um that a reboot
of fras you can watch a new one I'm so
[Music]
[Applause]
excited thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going home
[Music]